[Musik]
fast ihr halbes Leben schon ist sie
bereits bei der Bundeswehr stolz ist
Mandy Wagner Soldatin zu sein aber
enttäuscht wie wenig sie dafür von der
Gesellschaft zurückbekommt Ablehnung und
Desinteresse man ist einfach traurig
darüber dass man so
behandelt wird oder das dass man
eigentlich so man will ja den Menschen
helfen wir sind ja dafür da um um dieses
Volk zu verteidigen ja im Ernstfall um
den beizustehen um um das Land hier zu
verteidigen wenn die Wagner ist nicht
allein das was der neue
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius von der
Truppe hört ist der Wunsch nach
Anerkennung und Wertschätzung die
Aussetzung der Wehrpflicht nennt er
einen Fehler habe sie doch die
Bundeswehr in der Zivilgesellschaft
verankert ich glaube dass eine eine
Bundeswehr eine Streitkraft insgesamt
nur dann erfolgreich einen so wichtigen
Auftrag in diesen Zeiten erfüllen kann
wenn sie da ist wo sie hingehört und das
heißt in der Mitte der Gesellschaft
sowohl was Wahrnehmung angeht als auch
politische Prioritäten
Musterung
Kreiswehrersatzämter Bilder der
Vergangenheit seit 2011 ist die
Wehrpflicht ausgesetzt unrealistisch
dass sie in der bekannten Form
wiederkommt es fehlt an Strukturen
Kasernen Ausbildern und militärischer
Ausrüstungen ein wieder in Kraft setzen
der Wehrpflicht nur für Männer wäre
sicherlich in der jetzigen Zeit nicht
mehr möglich rechtlich nicht politisch
nicht ich weiß auch nicht ob das
richtige Signal wäre in der
internationalen Situation
denn es würde ja anzeigen dass wir von
einer spannungssituation ausgehen die
junge Generation ein Jahr von
qualifizierter Ausbildung und Arbeit
abzuhalten das ist nach der Pandemie und
angesichts auch unseres
Fachkräftemangels ökonomisch und
gesellschaftspolitisch damit bleibt die
Personalnot der Bundeswehr während die
Anforderungen der NATO im Zuge des
angriffskriegs auf die Ukraine zunehmen
das Ziel von der Zeit
183.000 Soldaten und Soldatinnen um
20.000 zu wachsen auf 203.000 binnen
acht Jahren
Versuche der Bundeswehr sich als
attraktiver familienfreundlicher
Arbeitgeber gegen die private Wirtschaft
durchzusetzen fruchteten eher nicht die
Bewerberzahlen gingen zurück doch die
Truppe muss wachsen die
Friedensdividende aufgebraucht eine
mentale Zeitenwende muss her
das heißt eine Einsicht vorhanden sein
muss für die Notwendigkeiten diese Armee
dieser Bundeswehr und auch für die
Bedürfnisse der Soldaten und Soldaten
und zu den Bedürfnissen gehören
natürlich in erster Linie die
gesellschaftliche Anerkennung die
Bundeswehr im Einsatz an der Ostflanke
klar ist das aktuelle Bedrohungsszenario
bringt mehr Rückhalt in der Gesellschaft
für höhere Verteidigungsausgaben und die
Landes- und bündnisverteidigung
mit der Zeitenwende
werden diese Einsätze und auch
potenzielle Maßnahmen in Litauen im
Baltikum in Polen mit absoluten
Mehrheiten unterstützt vorher vor der
Zeitenwende also 2021 hatten wir dann
eine unterstützungszahlen von 30 35%,
also da sehen wir eine massive
Veränderung offen inwieweit der Krieg
auch Respekt und Anerkennung für die
Soldatinnen und Soldaten mit sich bringt
Mandy Wagner zumindest erlebt derzeit
eine neue Wertschätzung die Gesellschaft
ist aufgewacht das ist traurig dass es
das dazu gebraucht hat aber das ist das
was ich jetzt erfahre wenn man unterwegs
ist
das ist jetzt wirklich dankbarkeit
zeitenwände ist nicht nur neues Gerät es
muss auch neues Denken bedeuten die
Bundeswehr muss zu einer neuen Stellung
in der Gesellschaft finden und das
voraussichtlich ohne Wehrpflicht